ever since the release of layers of fear
in 2016 blueber team's games have been
obsessed with getting you inside the
damaged minds of their characters
sometimes literally
this kind of psychological horror has
become blueber team's calling card and
just this week Konami announced blooper
would be developing the remake of Silent
Hill 2 giving them a chance to bring the
horror classic to a new audience however
their games have also attracted
criticism for their sometimes troubling
messaging around trauma and mental
health so what can we expect from
blooper's reimagination of Silent Hill 2
well whether it's through the Sci-Fi
setting of Observer or the supernatural
mindscapes of the medium one thing is
pretty clear blueber team wants to
create games that get inside your head
too what is the most exciting but what
we are doing is actually that we can
kind of influence the players bring this
feeling to the player that you are not
in control of what is happening around
you
if there's a Common Thread across
blueber team's games it's their emphasis
on the psychological roots of horror
bluebird's games tend to draw influence
from the internal struggles of their
characters to create disturbing and
unsettling horror experiences I spoke to
Mattress Leonard lead director of the
upcoming Silent Hill 2 remake a few
weeks prior to konami's announcement
matches joined blueber team just as they
began work on what would become layers
of fear their first horror game and took
inspiration from films that explore the
dark side of the human psyche movies
like seven cylons of the Lambs The
Shining was something that was a big
inspiration for me as you can see we
don't create like the gore type of games
right so I think those influences that
that me or or making has also are in
line with that right we don't want to
you know create a blood splatter on the
screen is not what we are how we are
working we are mostly creating an
atmosphere and psychological backgrounds
and for the players to be afraid of
though the settings may vary across days
of fear in its sequel Blair Witch
Observer and the medium blooper have
stuck rigidly to this subgenre for the
best part of 10 years with each game
aiming to draw you into the
discomforting psychology of their
protagonists psychological horror is a
sub-genre that you could argue has been
underserved by games since the
flatlining of konami's horror Flagship
so perhaps it's no surprise that blueber
team would pick to remake Silent Hill 2
particularly as the team are so open
about PT's influence on layers of fear
the idea was to play The Haunted House
again and then also like the obvious
influence was speeding from so we saw
that and it was like pretty big thing
back then and we you know we kind of
grab it okay so let's do something like
this after like one week or two weeks we
realized that we don't want to do that
like we want to do something more and
then you know the painter as a
protagonist the overall art background
and that's you know creates the path
that we that we follow laser fear puts
you in the shoes of an unnamed painter
exploring his dilapidated Mansion
functioning is a kind of haunted house
Simulator the player can uncover and
understand more about the character
through finding notes around the
environment hinting at his abusive and
neglectful Behavior towards his wife and
child his fixation on the house is rap
problem and most notably his declining
mental state one note written by a
doctor and apparently annotated by the
painter himself outlines the symptoms of
schizophrenia a commonly misunderstood
condition that does not relate to split
personalities schizophrenia causes among
other things hallucinations and
delusional thinking something that is
represented with worsening severity as
the player progresses a key component of
psychological horror is the idea of the
unreliable narrator the idea that what
the protagonist believes is not
necessarily the objective truth laser
fear allows the player to experience
that firsthand as the painter slips
deeper into psychosis the symptoms of
his condition begin to play out in
increasingly Vivid and unsettling ways
most notably through changes to how he
perceives the environment around him I
think the big game changer for us in the
first layers of fear was actually this
you know this concept of constantly
changing environment around you and it
was something that you know bring this
feeling to the player that you are not
in control of what is happening around
you and we tested for different angles
like whoa like this is something new
like this is something very very cool we
are like very nitpicking about the
environment that we are creating and a
specific character helps a lot because
you know having a painter and many doors
are just open for us how the painter
could see the world the result of this
is a nightmarish trip through a world
that seems to be drawn from the unique
psychological makeup of the protagonist
much as we see throughout the Silent
Hill franchise and particularly with
Silent Hill 2's James Sunderland however
unlike those games layers of fear
features very little of the survival
mechanics you might expect from a
traditional horror game there is no
combat and though you can die at the
hands of the game's monstrous entity the
actual penalty to progression is almost
non-existent this slower Pace extends to
the actual scares too with the balance
weighted towards atmosphere in a steady
increase of tension over constant jump
scares something Bluebird developed
through their later games and that
matches appears Keen to push further in
their upcoming remake the cheapest cares
are distinctious to do most of the time
and you know after creating like you
know several games already in Liberty we
are trying to you know
step back from the jump scares as much
as possible because we realized that
players are scared the most just through
the atmosphere and just their
imagination about what might happen
because the story that you are telling
me is like much stronger than you know
some like cheap jumpscar that will jump
on your face our Inspirations are
changing all the time and something that
might be fitting to the game like layers
of fear might not be fitted to the games
like this like the medium right we had
to have like completely different
approach for that kind of game like I
said like the best part the best story
is when you are connecting everything
every ingredient you are connecting to
the actual topic that you are talking
about this is a trend Blooper have
continued across their back catalog of
games layers of fear 2 Blair Witch
Observer and the medium all center
around horror escapes that are
reflective of the psychological state of
their characters individual traumas
fears secrets and regrets however it's
worth noting that louboutin's depiction
of these psychological conditions
questions and not without controversy
layers of fear essentially suggests the
painter's schizophrenia has turned him
into a monster and some have accused
bluber's most recent game the medium of
promoting damaging stereotypes about
survivors of trauma and abuse in the
media monsters are created in the spirit
world as a result of traumatic events
with the most severe traumas creating
monsters powerful enough to possess
people in the waking World some have
suggested the game's message that you
can't always save everyone paint
survivors of severe trauma as beyond
help an obviously inappropriate and
damaging message to be communicating
when dealing with the kinds of topics
the game addresses similar criticisms
were leveled at another title Blair
Witch the story of which deals with PTSD
and suicide with similarly Bleak
outcomes blueber team are hardly alone
in creating psychological horror art
that attracts controversy however it's
still important to portray these issues
in a considerate way and allow players
to inhabit characters struggling with
their psychological Health in a way that
doesn't stigmatize real-life conditions
and experiences through harmful
stereotypes whatever changes blooper
makes in the Silent Hill 2 remake like
the original they will almost certainly
attempt to put you in the uncomfortable
position of experiencing James's
subjective reality where the horror is
born out of his individual psychological
profile when that kind of psychological
horror is done right it gives the player
a rare opportunity to see through the
eyes of someone at the extreme edge of
their sanity or from the comfort of
their sofa another psychologist or or
anything like this but I think it's
connected with urge to experience
something that you are unable to
experience in your own life this is
something that reached the part of your
mind that you are not using you know
most of the times right this is
something new for your brain for your
you know for your comfortable zones what
was unique for me you know working in a
different companies throughout the years
and start working in Liberty most of the
companies like started from gameplay and
we most most of the time we are starting
from the story for the the premise from
the topic and from from the the
atmosphere and then the game plays
actually like mostly connected to the
story that we are trying to trying to
create we are trying to create
everything based on that
oh so I think this is this is something
that is pretty pretty unique